Let's say someone stops you on the street
and says, "Decide fast!
73 plus an empty space is 57.
How much is the empty space? "
There are several ways to find an answer.
The empty place is actually what you need to add
to 57 to get 73.
This is the difference between 57 and 73.
It can also:
"Ok, let me start at 57."
I will do so in my mind.
I'll start with 57
and I will add such numbers,
that I get nice rounds until I get to 73.
So I'll start with 57, I'll say, "Let me think.
I can easily get to 60 by adding 3. "
That's how I get 60.
And from 60 to 73 I can tell that I have to add 13.
It is easy to think in mind.
Or I'll add 10 to get to 70.
And then I'll add another 3.
But I have already decided: 60 plus 13.
Yes, this is 73.
Therefore, this whole thing is now 73.
How much did I add to 57 to solve the problem?
So 16.
So, 16 plus 57 is equal to 73.
But there are other ways to solve it.
You can say, "Yes!
The empty space is actually the difference between 73 and 57. "
This can be written as 73 minus 57
is equal to an empty space.
This will give you the same value.
You will get 16.
There are many ways to calculate it.
But that's the way I would try
to deal with the task in my mind.
Let's take a few more examples.
This is very, very fun.
So, say, someone
they stop in the street
and says, "Decide fast!
94 minus blank space
is equal to 57. "
That means: "How much do I have to get out of 94,
to get 57? "
Okay, I'll decide the same way,
as this time I will pull out,
I will draw numbers with which
is believed easily in the mind until he reaches 57.
And that's exactly how I'll calculate it in my mind.
I'll start from 94.
And I'll get 4 to get to 90.
So here is 90.
Let's think.
Then I'll get 20 to get 60.
I do not want to get less than 57.
So I'll get 20, 90 minus 20.
No, I'll actually get 30 to get 60.
So I can get 30 now.
So, 90 minus 30 will be 60.
Then getting from 60 to 57 is quite easy.
I just have to get another 3.
60 minus 3 will be 57.
And how much did I get out?
I took 4, 30 and 3.
Let's see now.
I took out ... 34, 37.
I pulled out 37, right.
But here's another way to solve.
You can say, "Yes!
37 is the difference between 94 and 57. "
So, you can think about it.
If I started 57, how much should I add,
to get to 94?
And you can apply exactly
the method from the last task where ...
Here I will add 3.
If he adds 3, I'll get 60; then if I add 30, I'll get 90.
And then, if I add 4 more, I'll get 94.
So I added 37.
Of course, there are other ways to solve this,
especially if you have a handwriting sheet.
But this is the way I will solve in my mind,
if someone stops me in the street
and asked me to solve these tasks.
Now let's resolve one more.
Let's solve another problem.
Let's see where there is free space.
So let's say someone asked,
"We have the following: 36 equals an empty space
minus 41. "
So let's think, "It is given,
that 36 is the difference
between the empty space and 41. "
And another way is to think that 36 plus 41
will be equal to an empty space.
You can apply this on the numerical axis.
If it is not quite clear that
these two expressions are the same,
then draw a numeric axis here.
And then it is given ...
"We will start with an unknown number.
We start with an unknown number.
This is our empty place.
We'll get 41.
We take 41
and we reach 36. "
This is the same as saying:
"If we start at 36 and we have to add 41,
we will go back to our empty place here. "
Then how much is 36 plus 41? Well,
let us collect the units first.
We have 6 units plus 1 unit.
That's 7 units.
And then we have 3 decades plus 4 tens,
which is 7 decades, or 77.
So that's 77.
And we're ready.